أنت تستخدم كلمة الراحة أريد أن
أعرف كيف يتم معاملتك إذا كان بإمكانك
كيف هي الحياة اليومية بالنسبة لك هناك، كيف
تقضي أيامك في إيفين،
صحيح،
انظر، هناك الكثير من
الأقوال غير المريحة على شبكة سي إن إن حول هذا الأمر
ولكني أعتقد
أم الإجابة المختصرة هي أنني كنت
أشعر دائمًا أن إنسانيتي ذاتها
قد سُلبت مني
وليس حريتي فقط
اليوم أنا في الجوائز العامة الآن
الوضع في الجائزة العامة
أفضل بكثير من زاوية  الجحيم الذي اعتدت أن أكون فيه
في مركز احتجاز، إنه
ليس مكانًا لطيفًا للعيش فيه ولكن
آه، كل شيء يصبح نسبيًا، لا يزال من
الصعب للغاية تحمل
الحقيقة الأساسية وهي أنني محروم من العديد
من حقوق السجين لأنني
رهينة
لا تعرف كيف تنقل
أنني أرى مجرمين متشددين أرى أعضاء
في داعش أرى أشخاصًا من
المتاجرين بالبشر لديهم حقوق أكثر مني
ولا أعرف أنك تعرف ذلك نعم
ظروفنا العامة في
الجائزة العامة هي  حسنًا، أود أن
أقول إن لدينا أفضل ما في
وسعنا للتكيف مع
ظروفنا،
وأنا شخصيًا أشعر بالارتياح لاستخدام هذه
الكلمة مرة أخرى وحقيقة أنني أعلم أنني
أفعل كل ما بوسعي لمحاربة هذا
الظلم الذي أريده
أقول إن وضعي اليوم
مختلف تمامًا عن
الأشهر الـ 27 الأولى من اعتقالي
عندما كنت لا أزال محتجزًا في
مركز احتجاز هناك، وكان وضعي محفوفًا بالمخاطر حقًا
ولم أشعر بالأمان على الإطلاق
وأريد أن أذكر أن
إدارة أوباما كانت تعرف بالضبط  كم
كنت غير آمن تمامًا، لقد تأكدت من ذلك
في تلك المرحلة كما لو كان
آسروني قد جعلوا من مهمتهم
تجريدني من أي مظهر من مظاهر
الكرامة الإنسانية، أقضي أشهرًا في قفص،
أقضي أشهرًا في أقفاص في زنزانة انفرادية
كان هناك حجمها  خزانة تنام على
الأرض يتم إطعامها مثل كلب من
تحت الباب وبصراحة كان هذا على
الأقل من مشاكلي
وأنا
حتى يومنا هذا أنا
آسف لأنني لم أدرك أن هذا
سيحدث
CMAC أنت تحت الإكراه الشديد
يومًا ما بعض المعالجين  سوف يجني
قدرًا جيدًا من المال